die junge ob du du bist ja und nein
neumodisch jetzt in anführungszeichen
dass man halt als als eigentlich
bedeutet da habe ich dir gegeben
mit deutschem hintergrund habe ich ihr
dass dekker gegeben
ja mit mit deutschem hintergrund
trotzdem irgendwie ein italienisch name
wird zum beispiel bei luca nimmt oder
ein amerikanisch englischen wie bei dem
ja oder david oder cindy oder gar nicht
dran
zudem glaube ich ihm so da war das was
ganz normales sowie gut ein damals war
aber bedeutet das ein bisschen mit dass
patriotismus dass die deutschen noch nie
selbstverständlich auch sagen ja
deswegen das meine ich ja und heutzutage
macht man sich jetzt so viele gedanken
also ich denke mal die 50 60 70 prozent
wenn ich mir wahrscheinlich mehr dem der
werden den eltern kaufen sich ein buch
wo namen dahin stehen ja irgendwelche
namen nachzugucken übernehmen könnte
gerade jetzt wo mobbing wieder ein thema
ist da will man das nennt man dann cool
und dann hat es keine probleme in der
schule und auch einmal danke dass du
dein luca
ich weiß ich habe es einmal durch
gerollt also ich denke das hatte damals
über beziehungen zur heutigen zeit es
hat nicht an die eltern denken ich an
mobbing sofort wegen dem namen
ich denke dass die einfach dem kind sage
ich mal was gutes tun wollen ich weiß
nicht ob ich so die eltern
identifizieren sich ja immer auch ein
stück weit mit dem kind und da die welt
sicher verbessert erneuert oder was weiß
nicht was dann ist denkt man halt
einfach moderner und alaska zu ist dann
weil es so ist dann ist es auch so basta
damit haben jetzt ob du hier bist du
nicht jemand von euch
akzeptiert ich habe mir 50 eisen wollt
ihr
ich nehme diese wolle an den reich
ranicki leider mussten wir nicht
wegnehmen wolle nicht an obwohl du den
extra gefragt wurde
wir haben gar nicht mehr beantwortet
findest du in meyer weiß ich ich finde
ich ganz cool lässig aber was hinzu
jeremy pascal die wege das kann jemand
die namen aufziehen von euch
ich habe mir was ausgedacht wie die
links da mache hier kommt ihr lasst euch
tot
diesen film ottos leben ja ich komme
nicht kommen wäre das ding ist ich hab
mir sowas gar das hätte so episch
ausgesehen hat aber noch nicht gefixt
lass mich in ruhe minecraft okay okay
wir das nicht in ruhe
ich komme immer way back und es war was
geht nicht
ich wollte so wenn ich die dinger hier
setze das sie nach links und rechts
verbinden und das hier trotzdem flach
bleibt hier oben immer eine fackel auf
das bett ist so geil aussehen wie so ein
anwesen
nein das funktioniert hier wieder schön
das verbindet links und rechts hier
kommt keiner rein findet sich das nicht
keine ahnung jetzt weiß ich endlich mal
aber es gilt auch wacker oder es wurde
extra in den weg gemacht
das wurde noch nicht hinzugefügt weil es
ja machen ja immer am ende erst jahr
zwei spiele man kann ja auch keine
fackeln an die seite setzen was auch
falsch ist
probier doch mal hier ein hinzusetzen
ein von diesen nicht von der eine mauer
in die mitte zu sehr ab so kannst gar
nicht in die mitte setzen
man habe ich jetzt umsonst 64 davon
gemacht
bekomme ich dann ganz leise nicht
verbraucht reisen
ich habe sagte 50 stück ausgenommen 50
stück
das ist nicht dein ernst aber ich habe
hier noch 625 alpen sind weg so geht das
nicht
du hast noch kabels dena jetzt nicht
mehr als auch noch diamanten
gerade habe ich kein gras ich kann der
kapitän ich bin der gastfreundlich bin
eher dafür dass man randgruppen wie cap
integrieren sollte ja auch für
integration aber nicht vor meiner
haustür integriert leute mit weniger als
drei buchstaben im namen
wo bist du denn weniger als drei
gemeinden habe ich eigentlich zwei steck
gremmel gesammelt wenn ich immer ein
braucht jetzt warte ich geb dir welcher
hier wer stehen bleibt stehen bleibt
nein ich gebe dir was kopiert dreisteste
und das darfst du ein kätzchen hat man
nicht zu viel an vertrauen das mal
aufgefallen ich habe ein steak bekommen
du hast mich verarschen ich hab dir
anderthalb sätze geben naja 16 und 18
sind für mich nicht eineinhalb noch
einmal schlagen dafür da hast du doch
was neid ich durfte ihn schlagen habe
ich mir so ein mini keller ein schöner
als labs man kann darüber spricht ganz
genau
dann könnten
bin auch immer mega um kati und kreativ
hier manchmal die manchmal baue ich
sowieso oder nicht mehr den das einfach
mega und kreativ und gerade ich habe
mich eva boot
obwohl nehmen habe ich doch nicht habe
ich nicht ich bin cool da wo ich
verstehe es nicht
ich kann dir leider keine erklärung
liefern
naja ich hoffe dass er mir alles
wegnehmen muss ja selbst nicht hierfür
probleme mit einem eisen 50 425
zurückgegeben
wieviel 26 habe ich jetzt zurückgegeben
wir haben 120
doch es geht noch trotzdem als der bofa
lass dir genau 88 raus komme ich wieder
und ich kapiere mal aus versehen 5 und
tracht 55 reisen genommen um einen zaun
truppen machen den jetzt ähnlich benutze
fenster oder sogar da oben mal
irgendwelche kinder einstellen möchte
oder so kleine cavs wenn ja wieder böse
waren aber in die ställe was ecke ab in
die treppe ketchup in die treppe eine
treppe ist dass die tat von seinen
eltern nicht kennen
doch das war noch nicht mal wie ich mich
immer viele als echte munition man
dieser den kassen so eine loch gefahren
er gibt an fahren
oh mein gott ok gut ich habe extra noch
mal unterm einer druckplatte geguckt ob
der täter ist ja heute traumatisiert
jetzt müsste jedes mal runter schalten
jetzt nicht gar keine mehr
er weiß was jetzt
du wirst jetzt nie wieder einen eine
druckplatte benutzen
ob werde ich richtig junge du hast das
nicht mehr wieder zu gebaut hier was du
offen gegraben hast wo war ich hab nix
offen begraben die sind travel bei mir
nein quatsch das warst du nicht ich doch
nie und das sage ich jetzt als wieder zu
bauen ja dann nehme ich mir sachen von
ok wat is dat sich wieder die hälfte
mitgenommen ich hab gar nichts gemacht
ich hab nichts ausgelassen klein
nachher drinnen laufen das war damals so
das fleisch von mir mitgenommen habe ich
lieber gehört junge ob du dumm bist
caillou und mein ohr juni wohl härteste
tnt herres der krieg hatte tnt wo er
hattest du tnt warst du was du hast
gerade meine scheiße gesprengt da war
nie eine druckplatte wie das was in die
luft geflogen war auf tour geht es nicht
ich war doch ich mal bei mir zu hause
oder soweit ich das von hier gesehen
habe was praktisch nicht ist sag ich mal
ja ich habe einen auf meiner seite wirst
du nie ob man jetzt sind wir mehr als
nur quitt alltag du hast das hier nicht
zugebaut und das bei mir was ein luft
gesprengt dafür bitte ich jetzt getötet
und bei dir was in der luft gesprengt
das aber ja annähernd das ausmaß hatte
die als es bei mir war bei mir wasser
und alles im spiel bei dir war es
wirklich nur ein halbes haus überhaupt
deswegen habe ich auch das bag erde
sogar extra noch gegeben alter damit ist
jetzt ungefähr zu bauen kannst doch
woher hattest du das tmt ich hab selber
gunpowder von krippen und halt sand
abgebaut abgewandt was nur sand formen
dafür
er hat jetzt als keller ist dass gerade
so ein bisschen was sonst ich gucke mir
mein werk jetzt mal an es ist ja nicht
erst stirbst du gemacht hast
eingerichtet 8 dem ganzen ging auch hier
die spitze aufgesetzt
man muss wissen wann schluss ist mein
freund
oh mann
womit habe ich das verdient indem du
angefangen hast jetzt ganze freitag
konnte ich keine möglichkeit mehr finden
ich irgendwie fertig zu machen
ich habe glaube ich keine angriffsfläche
mehr für dich ich werde was finden keine
sorge das wird ein spaß nicht nur das
alter die ganzen schafe panja schon
wieder man dafür richtig voll noch hier
drin
ich glaube sie hat schon fast zur freude
bin ich eigentlich längst in der neuen
folge ja schon längst die sind schon
wieder aus einer folge aus warteten in
20 sekunden wieder einer neuen hat mir
ist kein thema in der folge dass die
pascal folge riss nicht ab stand ja ich
glaube das war das mit den namen dann am
ende ist er bei dir damit dass man da
passiert wo ja selber draufgetreten bist
ja so ganz außer dem ball hast du das
gemacht hast du bei mir gremmel abgebaut
hast du bist so ein penner so ein
kleiner hitze ist laut alter so ein
morgen wie jung ich auch lieb
verbaut wieder verbaut bau dich in die
ecke 12 auf einmal bronze täterin und
opfer noch zusammen na ja jemand kriegt
man kriegt erfahrung wenn man tiere part
nicht wenn man sagt ich dachte wenn man
nicht an
und ich würde nicht bei ihm fahren wir
wieder nach hause gesandt erlebt eine
überraschung
ich brauche mal nach kerpen ja nichts
getan denke ich kann jetzt geben du und
wenn wir dafür dann auch mal irgendwas
am gefallen tust maß nicht ich muss auch
gucken
ich baue jetzt kartoffeln an der schönen
kate erste kartoffel gibt liebsten in
der kartoffel ab und dehner keine dann
gebe ich den 26 travel die einzel hass
krieg teil geschäft hinter meinem rücken
hinter dem rücken diesen vorteil
brückenseite du kriegst alles mit was
sarah kick für das gar nicht mehr kannte
projekt eine kartoffel ab weil ich noch
förderbeiträge behörde den us teil meint
sofort geschäfte verboten und alles ist
nicht weil sich seine behörde auch so
gut in unsere geschäfte untereinander
einmischen kann ja ich hab's und
wirtschaft halt stopp sowie klose ich
mache ganz viele koppeln
kelek bei mir ein bisschen ich lebe ja
auch ein bisschen viel expertise herbert
f ich lege bei mir auch ein bisschen
okay ich hole mal einfach so hier